just watching it live it looked like two
guys
hand fighting i thought it was well
executed uh i was so i was surprised
there was a call there
uh either way so
very obviously disappointed in the call
particularly at that point in the game i
thought they let both teams play tonight
and you know
you just don't usually see that
particularly at a critical point in the
game
it's one on one uh michael gallup's a
guy that that i trust every time
especially in a deep ball situation and
so i just put up put it out there
i'm trying to let him go run under it
from my point of view obviously you
can't see anything so
you can't see necessarily a push offer i
didn't see anything on that play but
some of you have to go back i'll have to
go back and look at it on tape it was
clear as day if they wouldn't have
called that then i would have been
highly upset um so
yeah that was clear as day in my opinion
i don't know what y'all saw but that's
it that's what i that's what i saw and
felt out there
ah oh he was selling it so well until
the end when he smiled i mean look this
is football
when something goes your way
you characterize it a certain way when
it goes against you you're unhappy about
it that's
all the broader dance of trying to
posture and position for calls chris but
that offensive pass interference call on
michael gallup i i tweeted last night if
gallop's wearing number 88 for the
cowboys that ball doesn't get called i i
just
it it was i you know it's i underst i
saw
i saw a little bit of that right there
was a little arm stuff but not enough
for a flag was there uh
for me there was mike i i think he's
laughing there because he's like you
know he wants to be like you know he
doesn't know how to react because he
wants to be like are you crazy
you know listen if they're not going to
call that on wide receivers then they
would forget defense
i don't know you know again they're
running at full speed when you can
put your arm back bar somebody and then
catapult yourself forward
as the other person gets pushed back
then damn let's just take the defenses
off the field
because the rules are but it's not but
it's not like ramsay was just standing
there being manhandled by michael gallup
they were both jostling
haven't we had that conversation so many
times about why
replay review wasn't appropriate for
pass interference because there's so
much of that stuff that goes on
and we're gonna pick it through frame by
frame to see what is and what isn't pass
interference yep i
i think one of the realities did not
have a replay review is the backup is
they throw the flag last night if there
was replay review maybe they wouldn't
have thrown the flag
and it wouldn't have been over time oh
cowboys would have been in business to
tie the game
i don't think so i don't i i from the
get-go
as soon as i saw it i went damn he he
pushed off you know again guess was
there hand fighting going on
certainly but he made the last big
aggressive move
no contact was made like that and when
you're running at that speed
that doesn't take much i mean it doesn't
again if the defender if the rolls were
reversed and the defender did that to
the wide receiver it'd be called
every time i mean and and then some even
if it was less egregious so
i don't have a problem with that i don't
i really don't
um it's unfortunate and i understand
that it could go either way in that
moment
but i did think that was past
interference now
there was another here's tony carrante
the referee
for the game last night said afterward i
can tell you it was clear and obvious on
the field
of a hand into the opposing player a
full-arm extension that created
separation
in all situations that would be called i
think he's
i think he's overestimating the quality
of the officials to say in all
situations that would be called because
one of the reasons why there's a strong
argument to be made
not to call it is we've seen that play
before and it doesn't get called
up i know you're right yes pass
interference is not perfect
we got to deal with it there's human
error involved and all that
you know but that that is one there
where i i think
we're all underestimating the effect of
whoa here's two guys running 4-3
and one guy gets to push off and go to
4-2 and knock the other guy
back to run in four-five and that's
that's that's there's no way
so i had no problem with the call um one
last question yes go ahead before you
pivot because i know you want to pivot
but i want to ask you one more question
mike mccarthy's comment on the call came
from the notion that that's the moment
in the game where you swallow the
whistle and you cram the
the flag deeper into the pocket i've
never been a fan of that i think the
rules should be the same all game long
but we see the human dynamics
where there's a reluctance to throw that
flag in that moment are you okay
with the flag coming out in that moment
or is that the let them play
phase of the game no i am okay with that
to me that that crossed
the uh the to me the egregious line
there it does to me i go no that that
you're letting too much go there
if it had stayed or it was hand fighting
hand fighting hand fighting
and then gallop just caught the football
i would have gone that's fine they were
both kind of doing it but it was hand
fighting hand fighting hand fighting
hard pushing the shoulder catapult
myself catch the ball
uh that to me is is too too much
do your hand fighting hand fighting fan
fighting hand fighting hand fighting
dude no no no
it's like that's like that's like a hand
fight between a couple of t-rexes
all right uh what was the other call
that that bothered you well
what kick a field goal i mean what
it's 20 to 17. it's fourth and three
your offense hasn't been the greatest
show on turf
your defense yes has been getting moved
on but the rams aren't scoring like
touchdowns they're not blowing you out
of the
the you know the sofi stadium
and just kick the field goal make it 20
20. if you think your team's a better
team on the field
just believe that the longer the game's
played the better team will
reveal itself but they took themselves
out of that right there and then had to
play from behind
and really couldn't stay with the style
of football they wanted to play because
now we're late in the fourth quarter and
we're down by three and we gotta
maybe can't be as patient with the run
game and things like that uh so i did
not like that call
yeah when it was 20 to 14 they kicked
the field goal to make it 20 to 17 on
fourth down and then was 20 to 17 they
they they skew the field goal and
uh it was a mistake and it was great
defensive play chris was
pointed out for the safety to get around
everyone and keep c.d lane from getting
to the stick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports